okay so this drill is like your net was
a road
it's not a fight i give you
some pressure but i have to coach you
okay you can dance out
stop it strike
trap uh whatever okay and so
it's slow motion just like rolling okay
it's just we're in standing position
okay and there's a gap and we have to
navigate
okay so here we go so i
i don't do goofy things though so i have
to make sure that i'm in range when i do
it
okay good and
tractor you're a little late
oh you'll have that if then so go ahead
and there you got
it you see so your thing has to be
uh with whatever you're doing
right
and if i have to use any muscle to get
it
that's not going to be right
so
keep your hands up
okay
okay so uh try to give this opening
don't force it right
try to come underneath look with my
watch me
so we're here don't turn
you want to push down right okay so i go
down
there you go get
good isolate good
okay let's check okay so this is not our
range
this is our our range okay because of
the leg weapons
if if he's if he if i'm this
close to him it's likely because he's
rushing in
and he's checking his own legs with his
aggression
secondly you don't chase things that
aren't going to touch you
so do that again i'll do the same
deviation there's no point in touching
the same thing goes for kicks i'm not
going here
that kick's not going to touch me
okay third thing uh
and this is the the problem with just
doing children wasn't
is you have an arm fetch okay
and you're not understanding the
the ik adhesion properly one maybe you
don't have one
but two you don't understand its realm
of application
so you end up with this arm fetish so he
goes in
and you're like trying to get the arm he
does the other arm how do you try to get
the other arm what
what happens instead as he goes he
he ends up he ends up there you see
and now i i'll stick to that thing
you see he ends up so he he
brought it he brought his arm back and
he ends up
in the overhook
at the underbed same way as if if he
uh i don't want to go from here i
have a check he brings his arm back i
follow the arm back and that's what ends
up
in that technique so likewise
boom they can respect your range
well i'm here that's my contact point
not wrestling for the arm i just ended
up here he's addressing
so if he's pushed me i'm gonna yield if
he's pulling away i'm gonna
enter but i'm gonna stick here okay
there we go boom
since dominated don't let it distract
you
boom boom boom hey here we are
i now have him in some sort of
trap but i didn't go like this
he's passing over me
here we are so depending on where he's
pushing
he's pushing this way then i'll yield
that way and that's my position pat
if he tries to go out i follow it out
yes again he tries to go around me
this way don't want to go around you
he goes around me right maybe i escape
but i'm not chasing limbs
there it happened on his own then
depending on what he does
that's what i do
so
you